それは言ったのはやっぱり
あの なんかあの 本物の宗教
なんか超自然的なところから何かコンタクトを取って喋ってる人の場合も
やっぱり誰からコンタクトを取ったかっていうことは教えの中に入ってるんです
もし宗教の中で怒りやら嫉妬やらね
もう邪教の人をもう責めません
責め 責めなさいというふうな
邪教だったら地獄だよと言っちゃったら
そこにもやっぱり怒りがある
みんな同じだよというふうな
この全ては梵が一流しか何もないよというところで怒りがないんです
ですから そちらの方々は面白いすると梵天のインスピレーションでヒンドゥー
ウパニシャッド哲学は作った可能性はもう十分あります
そういうのはまあ学問的に言えるものではなくて
このただ宗教の世界からそういう判断できますけど
学問的には私言うことには何の根拠もないんです
まあ一応根拠はあることあるんだけど
怒りがないとかね こちらに怒りがあるというぐらいは言えますけど
だからといって この人々は普通の神々からインスピレーションを取っていますよと
この人々は梵天からインスピレーションを取っている
それはもう証明できませんだからね
そこで無色界の次元にどんな心が現れるかというと
こういう心は生まれません
パタママッグ 預道は生まれません
ということは 無色界の次元にいる梵天には
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をそこでしてでも悟れないんです
もし悟った人がいたならば
例えば預流果の人は無色界に生まれたならばもうできます
あの預流果は得ているんだから
いわゆる不還果一来果阿羅漢果できます
が 預道預流果は不可能
無色界で そこら辺すごい細かいんだけど
その経典の中でお釈迦様もそれを明確に説明してるんです
そこら辺はやっぱり人間には関係ないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり高次元の世界ではね
そういう可能性不可能性っていうのは確実にあるんです
なんで無色界まで成長した人は悟らないんでしょうかというと
預流果になることはナーマとルーパが両方無常であると無我であるということを体験しなきゃいけないんです
ですから向こうでナーマでナーマを観察することはできますけど
その時もナーマの無常もそれほど観察は難しいんです
ルーパはまるっきりないんです
だから無常ということは堂々と経験は受け入れられない
受け入れられないんですね
ものすごいもうできません
とにかく ナーマルーパ両方ないんだから
だからナーマルーパ両方ある次元では悟られます
悟ったならば もう無常を体験しているならば
例えば預流果になった人であるならば
まあナーマだけ無常見ても構いません
それから二番目に現れない心はこの
色界の心 無色界にいる梵天には色界の心は生まれません
まあ生まれる可能性はないんです
色界の心には物質必要ですから
自分にはそれを持ってない
それからハサナチッタ
笑喜心 笑喜心というのは笑う心
我々笑う心じゃなくて
阿羅漢たちが笑う心 笑うためには体がないと笑えませんだからね
それも生まれませんだから
それからヘッティマ・アールーパ
ヘッティマって何ですか
寡無色 寡無色っていうのはこの
自分が無色界は四次元でしょ
四次元で 例えば無色界の三次元にいる人には
無色界の二次元一元で一元の心は生まれません
四次元にいる人には三番目二番目一番目の心は生まれませんと
自分のレベルより低いレベルの心は一つも生まれません
ということは欲界心も一つも生まれないということなんですが
こちらでまたそれ書いてない
あ 次に書いてますなんとか
サッバッタピチェッタンタンパサダラヒターナンタンタンドワリカヴィーティチッターニラバンティエーワ
まとめて言ってるんです
で パサーダ・ルーパっていうのは眼耳鼻舌身のこと
で 梵天に生まれたら目もあります
耳もありますけど 鼻はない
口はない 体で感覚はない
ですから体があるわけじゃないんです
結局は 音には反応する
光には反応する 梵天は
でも味には反応しない
観測には反応して 例えば素粒子と
素粒子と思ったら素粒子は何もぶつからないでしょうに
この物体がここにある
机がここにある この机に素粒子を
あの 流しちゃえば 素粒子は物質を通って出て行っちゃうんです
素粒子にとってはこんなこと存在しないんです
でも ここに机がある ここにボールを一つ落っこちちゃったら
ちゃんと机にぶつかっちゃうんです
だから梵天にとってはもう素粒子みたいな体だから
何もぶつかっても知らない
ぶつからない あまりにも細かいんだから
そういうことで体の感覚もないと
人間の立場から 立場で言えば
目はある 耳もあると 目はあると言ったって
私たちのように目 目ん玉があるわけじゃなくて
私たちのように耳があるわけじゃなくて
光に反応できる 音に反応できる
ですから色界の梵天には
あの ないものは心が生まれません
無色界の場合はその五つはないんです
体はないんだから 眼耳鼻舌身
全部ない ですから何にも反応しないということになります
そこでこのまた仏教でもう一つわけもわからない次元のことを言ってるんです
それはアサンニャ・サットと言うんです
無想無作 で 仏教でこの無想無作のことを言いながら
その瞑想だけはするなと
それまた否定しているんですね
他の瞑想全部あの 推薦しているんです
やってもいいと 無想無作瞑想だけはまあしてはいけないんだと
あれどういう瞑想かというと
あの 人が第一禅定に入る
それから修行して二禅定に入る
第三禅定に入る 第四禅定まで入る
入ったらこの あの 観察するでしょ
後の観察 このパンチャ・ワシー
五持再 いくらかはやっぱり五持再やらなかったら第四禅定までいかないんです
世の中の人々はたまに
あの 例えば偶然のような何か結果が出てでも第一禅定生まれる可能性あります
第一禅定生まれても 自分で努力しない限りは第二禅定生まれません
ですから もし人が第二禅定があったというならば
その人は間違いながらもこの五持戒はやってる人なんです
五持戒やらなきゃもう第二禅定には進まないんです
それで人が第四禅定まで行ったとする
そうするその人はまた五持戒の観察するでしょ
観察するその人はこう考えるみたい
この人間で瞑想する前に
私は苦しみを得た それ体のせいだと
当たり前でしたからね
そこで第二禅定を得たところで大変楽しかったと
でもそんなに第二禅定に比べるとそれほど優れた楽しみではなかったと
それは何のせいかというと
体のせいなんです 物質のせいだと
そこで第三禅定に入って
第二三定に諦めちゃったんだから
第三禅定に行くでしょうね
そこで喜だけやる 楽だけやる
で 前の禅定では喜も楽両方あったんですね
あれはあまり良くなかったと
第三禅定はなぜ良くなかったかというと
それ体だったんだからと
それで第三禅定から第四禅定に入っちゃう
第四禅定では何の感覚もない
ただ捨だけ ウペッカーだけ
ウペッカーと一境性 サマーディ状態
サマーディ状態あるんだけど
喜びもないし 喜悦感も全部もう捨てているんです
そこで考えるんです  第4禅定に入って
ずっとこの苦しみが来たのは体のせいだと
今自分が捨という感覚を味わっているのも
体として味わっているんだと
やっぱり悪しきものは物体だと
あ 間違った ずっと全部説明の言葉を入れ替え入れ替えなくちゃいけないんです
体ではなくて心だと 大変な失敗です
好かれてるんで もうそろそろやめなくちゃいけない
言葉を間違うと僕は結構好かれてるという証拠なんです
あの 欲界でなんで苦しんだかというと
心があったんだから苦しんだと
ものを見て心で判断して苦しんだと
心がなかったら何も感じませんだから
第一禅定はなんで良くなかったかというと
やっぱりそこに心が働いていたんだからと
第二禅定も三禅定もあまり良くなかったのは心が働いていたんだからと
今自分が第四禅定にいるんだと
第四禅定でも捨を感じているんだと
それも心がやってるんだと
その心さえなければ問題ないんではないかと
物質は大したことないんだと
何も感じないんだから
言って心に対する執着を捨てる
物質は別に放っておく
いわゆるナーマ・ルーパに分けちゃうと
ナーマはもう良くないんだと
ルーパは別に悪いものでもないんだと思って
ナーマに対する欲を捨てるんだけど
ルーパに対する欲を捨てない
捨てないでまた瞑想する
瞑想するとまた第四禅定が生まれるんです
二番目に なぜ第四禅定
第四禅定の人はなんで無色界の禅定が出てこないかというと
無色界は心でしょ 心は嫌がってるんですね
嫌いんですね その人が
体を置いておいて心だけになりたくないんです
心は嫌いだと 心は問題の種だと
それで瞑想するんだから
色界の次元は飛べないんです
瞑想しても ですから 第四禅定を得て
それが良くないと思ってまた瞑想するんだけど
二度目にまた色界の第四禅定が生まれるんです
その禅定の能力っていうのは
心を嫌うことによって得られるんです
そこでその人は亡くなったら心が止まるんです
あの すごい修行したんだから
だから無想と言うんです
心はないと 心はないんだけど
体があるかどうかもうわかりませんだけどね
ずいぶん後で書いてる本なんかでは体があるんだと
でっかい体があるんだけど
もうなんかこの柱みたいに
山みたいに ただいるだけで何も感じないんだというふうに
まあそれはわかりやすくするために書いてると思いますけどね
ある長い時間 その生命がここで死ぬ
死んじゃったらもう心はストップ
なんか悟ったこととほとんど同じ状態なんです
心もストップになっちゃいますけど
そのものすごい長い時間いていていていていて
それからまた心が活動し始めちゃうんです
エネルギーは まあ科学で言っていることと同じく消えません
なぜそこは仏教で否定していますかというと
心もそこで一時的にないんだから
その人には何もできないでしょうに
その次元で 自分がいないんだから
無色界に行ったら 例えば有色界になってから無色界に生まれ変わっても瞑想すればいいんです
心だけでもありますから
体なくても その人にはこれもできない
それで有色界になった人は絶対その次元には行かない
その無想定になるのはみんな凡夫なんです
有色界になるということは
ナーマ・ルーパ両方無常であるということを知っている人だから
有色界になったらもういくら瞑想しても無想定・禅定は作れません
最初から仏教はそれを否定しているし
その人にとってはそれはバカバカらしい
心だけあしきもんやということをバカバカらしい
物質も無常だからあしきもんでは両方あしきもんなんですね
ですから 無想定の次元に生まれ変わるのはこの凡夫だけなんですけど
その人々は長い時間 まあもったいないことをやっているんですね
何も成長ないことをやっている
その無想無想無想有情に生まれ変わったら
だから何の心も生起しませんと
あの あれに似ています
ニューメス定の状態とは似ていますけど
似ていることは似ているんだけど
それは解脱の世界ではないんです
じゃあそこら辺でやめましょう
間違わないように  [背景音]